all right
we
all right we are live
so hello everybody
month of november wow this last month
have been just completely insane like
just one of the craziest months
that i've been through but good like in
a good way not in a bad way at all just
a very good crazy
uh month all right let me just
just pop
put the chat out here all right
and so
i'm going to have a few announcements to
make before we
start um
and there is my friend brad nice to see
you brad in the chat that's good to know
that you're that you're there i always
forget to ask if there are going to be
moderators in the chat but it's good to
know
that uh that there are some
all right so
last month has been just nuts i mean a
lot of things happening a few things oh
lisa is there in the chat as well lisa
thanks for coming that's cool it's like
the middle of the night for her so it's
always awesome to know that she's uh
that she's there nonetheless
um
so
last few months have been crazy one
thing i forgot to mention at the last q
a is
um there are two priests so father
william bennett and father nick mihaly
father william bennett is at a saint
nicholas parish in new york city it's a
um it's a carpath russian parish and
father nick mihaly is also out of saint
nicholas parish in erie pennsylvania
they
last month they
they had
someone i think in in the parish in new
york had passed away and had left
a huge amount of books to the church
and um so father william knew father
nick knew that i had been flooded and uh
and that i'd lost all my iconography
books and so they arranged together to
send me like
just an amazing trove like 30 books just
amazing some books that i already had
that i'd lost and then a few amazing
classics that i didn't own and a few
surprises as well so
i just very grateful to those parishes
for um
for for sending me those books i mean it
it's a it's really is a treasure some of
these books are from russia some of
these books even if i wanted to find
them they would be very difficult to
find so thanks to uh to uh to both of
you father william and father nick
so this month has been god's dog
basically if you guys want to know
what's been going on the biggest thing
and so we started god's dog on halloween
october 1st last month
and i really shot up we we had put a
minimum goal of 30 000 just to be able
to like print the amount that we wanted
and uh we shot past that in the first
day went to like 40 000 in the first day
and then within a week we had reached a
hundred thousand
and uh of course it slowed down a little
bit after that but we're still going you
know every every day we still add about
a thousand dollars every day we're at
133 000 uh over i think we i think we've
we've gone over 2 000 books
and uh going out and so it's just really
amazing we've had some great
coverage we have articles written by
post-millennial geeks under grace
liberty nation
i'm going to be on matt frad's channel
in a few days a few things that were
recorded that haven't come out yet
so um so i'm just i'm just really
grateful so if you haven't
back god god's dog you know it i i
really
i don't know it's like i i've been
talking to a lot of people and we really
feel like there's a moment right now
there's a moment in a there's a time for
a shift in storytelling and uh we're
just really excited that we can play a
little role in this the uh so it's the
first graphic novel in a series
and uh so go ahead it's at godsdog.com
if you want to back it there are plenty
of stuff um you can get a signed saint
christopher print uh carving from me
it's the only time that i'm going to
print out this and christopher
image and it seems it's pretty popular
because uh because i'll be signing a lot
of stuff let's say so um
so yeah so i've just we've just been
really excited about that now one of the
things we're going to do
is we're going to do an nft project with
god's dog and this has been super
interesting to me because
i think this is possibly the most
controversial thing i've ever done
who would have thought you know i'm
writing i basically wrote a book about a
dog-headed saint who's with saint
christopher who's a dragon slaying saint
and with the leviathan and giants and
nephilim and all this stuff um you know
i've done talked to the some very
controversial people on my channel but
it seems like doing an nft thing is the
most controversial thing that we've done
uh but
and i've been thinking a lot about it
and some very some people that i respect
quite a bit like uh um
um
like vin armani uh who has writ who has
written me and expressed some
some you know some questions about why i
want to do this and and you know the
question of nfts themselves and so i
talked to meteor about it quite a bit we
talked for like half an hour on the
phone and uh i'm gonna put out a video
on the symbolism of nfts in the next
maybe a week or so or maybe two weeks if
i don't have the time and uh trying to
maybe explain how the nft is related to
something like saint christopher how it
has to do with the margin it has to do
with something like a place where heaven
and earth don't completely meet and what
function that can play in a system and
so we're going to talk about that but
the nft the nft
thing that we're setting up is going to
be related to the story itself and so
we're going to put out um different
levels of rarity in the nfts and they
will unlock
secrets that are related to the story of
god's dog and so some symbolic uh
secrets even a cryptographic secret and
then ultimately the top level will
actually have an extra page of
of of the comic book which will also
reveal something which is kind of hidden
in the story and which is coming later
also which will be revealed a little
later in the story so we're just excited
to see to try to use this the nfts as a
way to to think about ownership and to
think about secrets and to think about
cryptography all of this and so we're
going to be putting that into the very
system that we're setting up
and so if you're interested in the nft
project you have to send me your email
you have to find my email on my carving
website and send me your email address
we already have over a hundred people
that are
uh involved and so uh this will that'll
be launching in the next two weeks
before christmas for sure and so yes so
that is happening and the biggest thing
i think like one of the i guess in a way
it's even bigger but for me it was it
wasn't as big because i recorded it
several months ago but jordan peterson
finally put out the discussion
that we had with bishop baron and john
viveki also he put out a talk that i
gave at the jung
association in montreal and so that's
been i mean it's been great to to to
just
have these ideas bubbling out and in the
wake of that i also published a talk
with bishop baron and john vervicky on
my own channel so most of you are here
probably aware of that going on
but it's just been great and a lot of
opportunities people reaching out to me
really interesting people and hopefully
we'll see what plays out you know um
jordan has been
has been really really great and trying
to introduce me to all these theologians
in uh
in cambridge and these theologians in
washington dc and all these people so
it's kind of funny because i'm still
introduced as a russian orthodox icon
carver which i think at this time has
become a pretty it's always become like
a joke it's like here's this russian
orthodox icon carver and now he's going
to talk about uh the relationship
between genesis cogsi and phenomenology
so anyways it's pretty funny i actually
kind of enjoy still being called an icon
carver at this point
um so uh so yeah so that's something
that's going on what else is there to
talk about okay so yeah another last
announcement is
this week um i am uh i'm i'm making i'm
i guess it's because it's cyber week and
everybody's having sales and on their
different platforms so i'm having a sale
this week which started
last it started at the beginning of the
weekend and it's going to last until
december 4th and the sale is on kind of
all my platforms if you on my merch
platform symbolicworld.store
you can get 15
and also for my icon carving classes you
can get 15 percent and at checkout it's
pajeo15 so if you want it to get into
that i'll probably post be posting a few
ads during the week um just to make sure
people can take advantage of that if you
want to get christmas gifts it's it's
still time
to uh to do that and so yeah so so many
things going on
um
so all right so let's just go so lisa
says is johnny doing money laundry not
at all the funny thing about this is i'm
not going to get any of this money the
the nft project and the crowd funding
for indiegogo i'm not going to take any
profit from it i've i've
kind of but the reason why i want to get
to gather this money in the crowdfunding
and the uh the the uh nft project is to
have funds to invest in the next book so
that we don't have to wait and we don't
have to
let's say we have the freedom to hire
artists if we need to we have the
freedom to maybe even print it on our
own budget if we have enough money and
and distribute it through amazon if we
have to so if we if we can so we're
trying to figure out a way to get enough
funds so that we don't have to be
dependent on anybody and we can just
put out the story the way we want to and
so i'm not going to be making any money
from this nft project
all right okay
so here we go so let's start on the
questions and so these questions so that
most people might know the uh people who
support me on patreon at 10 or more they
can ask questions
in advance and we have too many
questions we used to open up super chat
so people could ask questions here but
it's just become too unwieldy so uh so
what we have now is moderators going
through the questions and picking
questions that haven't been asked many
times picking questions that are clear
and so we we're trying to limit
ourselves at around 50 50 questions
for uh for the q a and so so uh so yeah
so if your question didn't get picked
this month try to write a more clear try
to write a clear question and try to see
if that question has been asked before
um you usually can find questions as
clips in on the clips channel to know if
for you if that question has been asked
before all right so 10 minutes of
announcement that's a lot of
announcements all right guys sorry but
it's just been a crazy uh it's just been
a crazy month
all right
okay so here we go so we start with the
symbolic world website
so c streetzell asks
explain the symbolism of the orthodox
icon of the holy trinity it has three
angels sitting around a table where
abraham's offering has been
placed right and so a related question
on the trinity also hyjonathan i've
noticed that in some renditions of
rublev's trinity icon the head of the
calf is depicted in the bowl on the
table is this simply a remnant of the
icon's origin as the hospital
hospitality of abraham or is it
something symbolic there's something
symbolic going on
um and so yes yes and yes
so
i mean the symbolism of the orthodox
icon of the trinity especially the one
by
rublev what
did is that the image of the hospitality
of abraham is one of the oldest images
we have versions of it in some of the
early roman churches there's a mosaic
for example in saint mary um saint mary
major where there is a little mosaic of
the hospitality of abraham
and uh in that
um you know
the hospitality of abraham is when the
three angels came to visit abraham and
abraham served them a calf but also it's
the moment where the angels discern that
sarah is pregnant
but the image of the three angels
has been seen by the church fathers as
an as an image or as a
a hinting of the trinity from the very
beginning and so
what rublev was able to do was that he
was able to reduce the image to its most
simplest terms in the older versions you
would see
abraham and sarah coming to serve the
angels you would see for example
young man's you know
sacrif killing the the calf so you can
see different things in the image but
now in the version of rublev you really
have it simplified and and the way that
it's done it's very powerful because
the way that the angels are sitting
around the table they open up
in a manner
that
you know it feels like you are coming
towards the table and so now the table
in the icon of rublev becomes of course
the eucharistic table it becomes a table
of uh the of the sacraments it also in a
way becomes a hint at at um
at theosis at divinization that is that
the trinity is asking
us
to
um
to join into the life of the trinity to
par to come and
and be with them in their communion and
so to participate in that communion
um and so the angels aren't identified
as the different members of the trinity
but usually uh the way that it's
understood is at least for sure uh the
the i the image of the angel in the
center is christ because of the color of
his vestments and because of the way
that he's kind of holding his fingers um
and then after that it becomes
a little more ambiguous i would say in
terms of interpretations i've read
several and i'm never completely
satisfied with the interpretations as
for the calf which is on the table i do
really believe that it is
suggestive of the eucharist and it is
suggesting the uh the sacrifice of
christ and of the relationship between
uh the blood the the flesh
and the bread and the wine so
that's what's going on there hopefully
that answers that question it's a it's
probably one of the most famous orthodox
icons
at this point
all right so
cormac jones asks the stories i was
raised on were all either materialistic
or humanistic and harmful ways
which have caused me to develop an
emphasis on discernment as a survival
technique
as a result i also have trust issues
with stories i'm suspicious of
mythologies other than those central to
the church which have never hurt me
painfully this distress forms a barrier
between me and my irish ancestors who by
all accounts belong to the church but
whose stories can stray from the center
can you help does it have to do with
stores being garments of skins
um
[Music]
well you i mean you could understand
the idea of garments maybe not you could
say garments of skin but you can
understand that there's a hierarchy in
stories and that that's really the way
to to deal with it and so
if you if you have a kind of level field
where you believe that all stories are
the same and that all of them have the
same importance and i can see why it
would be a struggle for someone like
that to
be able to sympathize with some ancient
mythological stories or folk tales or
fairy tales um but if you have a proper
hierarchy then it it doesn't bother you
so much because you see them as kind of
flowing out of the central story of
christ even though they might precede it
in time you can see it as whatever is
good about those stories is that which
kind of hints towards these mysteries
and i think it's really important to be
able to have other stories besides the
biblical stories because
sometimes it can help you see things in
the biblical stories that you didn't see
before and so by being able to notice
the similar patterns and sometimes
similar but contrasting patterns in
other stories and in other folklore then
it can it can help you um
yeah it can help you see the stories in
the scripture more clearly
it can also help you see christ more
clearly um and so you can say that it's
like that for every exterior thing that
every exterior thing
you know um in the proper in its proper
place
can actually help you see um
can help you see christ more clearly
so jay grubb asks roberto echo is
interesting given his massive knowledge
about medieval and renaissance europe i
don't quite know how to take his novels
however it wasn't it was interested to
know if you have any thoughts in
particular i just finished fuco's
pendulum which seems to adopt a position
halfway between post-modernism and
symbolism is inevitable and that the
plan for ruling the world appears to be
put together by cynical tricksters as a
joke and yet appears that they were
being used to bring about the plan
and so
i mean umberto echo is definitely a
materialist and a and a uh a materialist
in all the
in all the worst ways he he has a
a lot of knowledge about not only about
the medieval tradition but also about
kind of western tradition and western
esotericism you see his knowledge of
western esotericism more clearly in
fukuo's pendulum for sure
um
and there are some interesting things to
to glean from him you know i myself you
can it can help you understand a little
bit
the problem of causality for sure like
the way that you talked about how
infuko's pendulum what happens is they
you know the people who are kind of
talking about all these secret societies
they basically invent a secret society
that doesn't exist
then in inventing this secret society
that doesn't exist it creates a vacuum
that attracts all these these types of
people that are looking for mystery and
looking for secret societies and so the
society ends up existing in the end even
though at the outset they just made it
up and so it can help you actually
understand you know how causality works
and how um
let's say in how the idea of the placebo
the placebo idea could be raised up into
other forms of of existence but i do
think that in the end he is
i don't think i don't think that umberto
echo believes that symbolism
has a reality the way that we think it i
think that he probably sees it as
projections of the human psyche that
nonetheless
can have an effect on the world because
we live in a human world
but i've used i've used for example like
uh forget the name of the characters but
in one of the in fukus pendulum there's
a the girlfriend character at some point
she does this amazing deconstruction of
symbolism and she basically talks about
how you know the reason why the head is
related to
to let's say heaven and all these higher
notions is that you know you don't knock
your head against things rarely you know
but the feet you knock your feet against
the ground and and you know she she
reduces it to like these super basic
bodily body
features
uh quite crass also actually um
but i keep i kept thinking and i think i
wrote this in an article that she's
right like umberto reco inverto echo is
right in that understanding it's just
that he doesn't understand
that it's actually a reflection of real
patterns in the world and so you know
there is a relationship between feet and
darkness and dirt and all these things
and it plays out symbolically uh in a
true analogy so it's not um it's not
just a projection
all right okay
so david flores says i discovered since
siemens style it recently and was
excited to see that you have
incorporated him into god's dog
please elaborate on what is your
favorite symbolism from his life
and so i mean simian is awesome because
you know so since simeon basically is a
saint who
lived on top of a pillar and he just
stood there on the pillar
um and he just prayed all day he did
prostrations and he prayed and um
he became basically the center of a
monastery at some point everybody
started flocking to him kings would come
and ask him his advice you know um there
are
there are like these stories about how
people who would want to go up there to
do them harm would just die you know in
strange accidents so what
so he's just there at the top of the
world
and he basically acts as an as an
authority figure and it can help you
understand how just placing himself up
there in humility because that was
really important because
um at some point people thought that he
was just being arrogant and so the um
the the ecclesial the ecclesiastical
hierarchy came to see him and they they
saw him at the top of this pillar and
they said all right you come down right
now and he just didn't ask any questions
just started coming down the pillar and
they're like no no no stay stay stay up
there if you're if you're gonna be if
you're gonna actually obey us to come
down so easily stay in the pillar and so
he stayed there and so you can i can
help you understand also how
how stillness can be
the cause of action right how someone
cannot do anything
but still become a kind of motor
for other things to uh to work and other
things to exist and so simeon acted
almost like the axis of a wheel like
this still point in the middle around
which where the world started turning
and
so for example there are these
traditions that they took the the acts
of the count the
the um of the council of nicaea to him
and that he had to kind of approve them
and there was this sense in which if he
didn't approve the uh the acts of the
council that you know who knows maybe it
wouldn't have been it wouldn't have been
um
wouldn't have been uh orthodox though
all right so patrick asks hi jonathan
thank you for all you do
i'm trying to write a short story for
the christ and token conference and
can't get out of the feeling that my
ending is a deus ex machina can you talk
about the symbolism of this pattern
specifically if there are any positive
examples in stories or if it is
generally just lazy storytelling
and so
i think it's possible to use
the so for those who don't know a deuce
machine is a solution
which appears at the end and basically
solves everybody's problem but it it is
not a solution which appears out of the
process let's say the psychological or
the process of the story itself right
and so it's like uh superman appears at
the end and just you know gets all the
bad guys and so it isn't that's the
story right so you you get you get um
you get uh
versions like that you know of stories
and ancient stories especially the greek
stories that's where it comes from the
greek world that they would use this
story and so and aristotle really wanted
stories to
to resolve themselves out of the
psychological reality of the characters
or out of the
the out of the the story itself right so
the story itself would resolve would
have the elements in order to resolve
the story so i think that it is possible
to play with the deus ex machina ending
but you would have to be very aware of
what you're doing
and you would also
have to
you just have to do it in a smart way
but um
i don't know what else to tell you but i
would say it's probably better
to um
to resolve the story out of its own um
out of its own logic
sorry
so gartner brothers asked the apostle
john ends his gospel saying
jesus did many other things as well
if every one of them were written down i
suppose that even the whole world would
not have room for the books that would
be written what do you make of this
yeah
i can't help but see a connection
between this passage and the fact that
the christian story permeates most other
stories so in this way the acts of jesus
that john doesn't have space to mention
truly i filled the whole world is this a
stretch no it's not at all a stretch i
think that's exactly what they're
implying i think that they're basically
implying the idea that
that what christ did does fill up the
world and that you know there here's a
limited version of it but ultimately
you know not only now but you could say
in
all of time it will
basically fill up the whole world and i
think it's also a way to
to connect christ to the divine logos at
the
at the the beginning right the saying so
it's like you know in the beginning was
the word and the word was god and the
word was god and so this word shines
into god moves into the darkness and so
you start with um
you start with you know i i've often
showed i don't know if
some of you will have seen this but i've
talked about how in the icon of christ
the pantocrator icon you have christ
with his right hand
uh speaking right this is a speaking
gesture you know or or uh or blessing
and so you have christ doing a direct
gesture
and then you have in his left hand he's
holding a book so there's this direct
and indirect which is related to also
the beginning and the end right the the
start and the finish and so you can see
it that way in that pattern which is
that the story starts with logos light
you know uh
god and then ends with the idea that the
world
could be full of book of of
could if the the acts of christ were
written down the world would would
become a book or be full of a book and
so that's the book that christ is
holding you could say in his left hand
it's a good way to understand it you can
understand it also as the uh as the the
heavenly jerusalem as this this fixed
thing this fixed civilization this
structure that is now fully kind of
revealed and fills up the the cosmos um
so that's the best way to understand it
in my
opinion
so a bit not bothered says you mentioned
the movie mid-summer in a previous video
the main american student characters
seem not to understand that the
participation in the festival has
serious consequences regardless if they
believe in it in the current culture war
what do modern secular people not
understand
about participation thanks
i think i think that it's a good
intuition that i think that what's going
on even now is that people don't
understand that it's about participation
and so even though they will participate
and they do participate they don't
necessarily understand the stakes of
participating and so
the fact for example that
the fact for example that the state at
in many places for example where i am
wants us to actively do certain
things
that permeate all the way into our
churches all the way into our
into our our relationship right is about
participation and so you know the masks
and and all of the social distancing you
know i saw a video today where the
spanish what is the spanish prime
minister saying that they're not going
to remove the mask even if even if kobet
finishes as long as there's the flu
they're going to keep the mask it's like
so it can help you understand that
that it's about part it's about
making people participate
and so i think that that people don't
realize that this is what's going on so
by making you participate
it's much it's much better for you to
become what they want you to be
than having you agree or disagree with
what they're saying you know by
physically embodying and doing things
then you are
you are colonized in a way that is far
more um
far more embodied or far more it goes
deeper than just
saying so that you think this or that
you think that
so i think that for sure people don't
seem to understand
what's going on in kind of let's say
yeah let's say reprogramming us in a
certain manner
um so sierra last asked is there a
difference between the earth and the
world or difference
difference between heaven and earth and
the world
how do we understand the difference
symbolically
so i mean i think that the earth in the
it's that heaven and earth in the
primordial sense earth is just uh
potential
and so
so you can have different relationships
between what's above and what's below
and so when we talk about the world it's
usually
to a certain extent something which is
manifesting heaven which is which is
actively manifesting heaven whereas the
earth at least in genesis and at the
outset is like something like darkness
it's just this potential for existence
so i think there's a it's a little
different but it the reason why you
think it's the same is not it's not
silly it's because you know we often
represent the duality of heaven and
earth or heaven and what's above and
what's below as what is
non-manifest
let's say heavenly pattern and what is
manifest
and so what is happening and so in that
way it's not a completely silly uh
relationship that you're doing um it's
just that you can see it you can see
this opposition in many ways you can see
it like i said like like that of that
which is invisible and pattern and then
the the manifest patterns in the world
or you could see it as
that which is invisible
and pattern and that which is invisible
and potential and then in the middle
being the world of the cosmos as the
joining of the two and both are totally
appropriate it just depends on the
circumstance and what you want to
emphasize but it's good that you're able
to distinguish them as well
right so alberto says uh
i'd be interested in what you think of
this i'm watching your recent jung
society talk i was remembering that
gowdy on many of his buildings crowns
them with a cross
but he uses a three-dimensional cross
that resembles the origin in a cartesian
sense that this ties with your
explanation that at the top is the
origin and from it comes reality yeah
for sure a three-dimensional cross is
one of the let's say it's almost like a
more powerful version of the cross
itself because and it's not these
three-dimensional crosses exist um
you know on churches as well they're not
just on gowdy's buildings they they
existed on other on other churches you
know and so you can understand that as
the cross and its fullness because it is
like the four direction of the earth and
then the vertical axis of the world you
can imagine like an axis and a wheel
with spokes and so it really is a it's
one i think it's definitely the most the
fullest version of the cross is
something like
something like a three-dimensional cross
um so yeah your inside is quite good
on that
for sure
so joey says hi jonathan can you explain
the connection between the divine
liturgy and the dinner table
how are these rituals connected and
thank you in advance so
so the liturgy or you know especially
the
the eucharist has many aspects to it and
so the relationship between a dinner
table
is one of them it's not the only one and
we have to be careful because especially
in the modern times especially um
um
it's like the catholics and vatican ii
and then maybe before that some
protestant strains before that they tend
to want to reduce
the
to remove the sacrificial aspect of the
eucharist to remove the altar aspect of
the of the eucharist and make the altar
just
into a table like a a meal a table meal
where we like i talked about in the icon
of the trinity where we're invited to
come and eat so we're invited into
communion at this dinner table
um
so there is a but there is a
relationship it's not it's not it's not
just that and so you can understand that
the manner in which you eat together at
the table
with your friends with your family you
are manifesting
communion
that is you are
you are feeding on the same body right
from below that is you're eating the
same potential
and you're manifesting uh team like
you're manifesting a communion because
you're sitting together and you're
looking at each other you're speaking
with each other and so eating together
is very powerful it's a very it's one of
the most powerful uh symbolism that we
have it's also so primordial right and
so so you can understand that it's it's
eating together at a table
is participating and embodying
the communion of the people that are
together
because you don't eat with strangers you
can eat next to a stranger right in a
restaurant in a cafeteria but you don't
eat with them it's not the same we know
it's not the same when you eat with
someone you are you are engaging in an
act of communion with them so now
take this up to the highest level that
you can and you can understand that one
aspect of the eucharist is that which is
that we are all eating the same body and
blood of christ
we we offered that body up as bread and
wine you know and now it's coming back
to us as the blood and body of christ
and as we eat it we are also becoming a
body we're becoming the church we're
becoming the body of christ and that is
the ultimate form of communion and so so
communion eucharist is a meal
um
and in that sense it has
a higher version of the same type of
symbolism that you have
you know when you're sitting with
friends or at the in a family
eating together at the table
all right so ramal says hi jonathan any
thoughts about bhagavad gita and vedic
lectures and how it differs from our
christian perspective recently seen your
video about buddhism and the
all and the one about duality and the
clips channel thanks for all your work
and so i think like it's the same you
know with
just like anything in in uh
in vedic uh literature
in the stories you know in the the um
the kind of epic stories that exist in
the in india the bhagavad-gita as well
there are some very powerful gems to be
found there
you know in
advanta there are things that are very
resemble uh christianity in terms of the
even their metaphysics you know it goes
so far that someone like david bentley
heart says that he's uh
that he's basically a christian
vedantist you know and so
and so there are relationships to be
found and you know you see that for
example i mentioned recently how there
is definitely a relationship between
uh
the bodhisattvas
that sacrifice their nirvana out of
compassion
for those that are still in the world
and the manner in which
the
the man in which the saints also act as
patrons for us in in the world as well
and also the idea that you see sometimes
in orthodox writings about how you know
people almost re someone was telling me
this about centers
it's a catholic catholic uh saint that
supposedly she she wrote in in her
in her text that she would not go to
heaven
not go to heaven unless all would go to
heaven something like that and that she
would remain until the end of the world
in order to pray
for
those who
those who
those who are left behind and so you
know you see a little bit of that now
the problem is always a problem of
hierarchy it's always the the problem of
people
seeing things equally and therefore they
won't be able to discern
the story you live in the story you
participate in the story which feeds you
um
and these secondary stories for you like
these stories that appear as interesting
as secondary as fascinating surprising
you know and so it's all about
so it's all about hierarchy it's also
about hierarchy of attention so if
you're a christian but all you read
is are the are the different sutras like
all the you know different uh mahayana
sutras then
there's a problem right there's a
problem in the manner in which you're
dealing with your christianity you
probably have to
you know reorganize your hierarchy of
attention in order to make sure that you
you're not you're not uh becoming
schizophrenic and kind of alienating
yourself so so yeah so i like i said i
think they're different i've i've i've
quoted the bhagavad gita and i've quoted
uh
i think i think i've incorporated uh
ramakrishna
uh
and like weird uh not ramakrishna why am
i mixing up that name anyway it doesn't
matter some some advaita vedantist like
i've quoted them uh
before and so i think that it's that
it's uh that it's possible to do that
i'm pretty sure i mix up that name i
think didn't i think that was the guy
from theosophy that i just mentioned
which no i would never cite that guy
um all right sorry see it told you i
don't really know much about hinduism
not at all all right so paul jordan says
please help me to understand the serpent
imagery in early american revolutionary
symbolism
i've been thinking about this
late a lot lately and i just don't get
it i know that many of the american
founding fathers were deist and
freemason i'm pretty confident that most
of them were raised anglican and
therefore would have
a thorough understanding of what a
serpent imagery means from a christian
perspective
put this alongside the long mystical
catholic and orthodox of course
scriptural tradition of portraying our
lady trampling serpent underfoot and i
don't get why these men
were so willing to use it
so i don't think i've ever seen that i
don't know like i would have to see what
the actual uh
what the actual thing is let me see
so i'd have to see you like what the
what it is that they're that they're
that they're using um anyways i'd have
to look into it i probably
i guess just have to do with the idea of
the
the snake being cut up in terms of
liberty or i guess the don't trade on me
symbolism
um
i mean i have to think about it the
snake is not bad in itself and you know
i've mentioned you know like i've
mentioned it before uh
uh bishops in the orthodox church have a
staff with two snakes on it you know and
often the iconistasis will have dragons
and snakes on them and so it's not like
like snakes are bad in themselves
but um
you know i think that often it seems to
me that
the the snake in the in the american way
especially the don't tread on me idea
it has to do with a refusal of authority
and so it's the idea that right there's
a snake on the ground like the don't
trade on me sing was a good example it's
like it's like don't
don't try to impose something on me
or else i will bite you right from below
i'll get you from below and that and uh
and uh and i'll you know
and so i think it seems to have
something to do with the refusal of
authority and if you look at that image
that i was i just saw of the serpent
getting cut up
getting cut up uh
then you could think of it something
like you know we have this serpent which
is very powerful to come up and bite the
king and to kill the king to kill to get
rid of the authority and so if we if we
cut it up you know then
then we don't if we're not together if
we're not joined together then we won't
have that power to strike from below
and so you could say that that is
possibly subversive because
you know it's makes sense with the
symbolism is coherent but it's uh it's
also a little scary to think of that
would you that you imagine yourself that
way as this as the snake that will
refuse all authority you know
yeah and i mean it goes to it
it says a lot about the problem of
american culture like that i'm not like
i've said before i'm not a libertarian
you know i can i can complain about a
lot of the insanity that i see in the
modern state and the insanity that i see
in uh
in these kind of the these
you know the government's becoming
stronger and stronger but i'm also
definitely not a libertarian i i think
that hierarchy is inevitable and so
so i i'm not attracted at the you know
at the outset as for
towards images like this
all right so hi jonathan i'm asking this
question as a request from my 15 year
old nephew carlo this is eric salander
asking
he wants to know the meaning of the
meteorite striking the statue in
daniel's interpretation of the dream he
has started to go to liturgy with me as
well and i'm very proud of the way he's
excelling in life well cool that's
awesome eric
um eric has written some really great
articles on the symbolic world website
by the way if you guys want to check it
out
um
okay so
so it's not a meteorite i don't know why
you think it's a meteorite it's the it's
the idea of an of a of us an uncut stone
a stone not cut from human hands and so
maybe you could interpret it as a
meteorite but usually that's not the way
that it's that it's interpreted uh it's
like a stone which falls from a mountain
you see that the the emulate the images
of for example the mary sometimes she's
called the uncut mountain nor the
mountain from which the uncut stone has
come down
but in terms of the actual symbolism of
uh
of the statue of daniel you have to
understand it as
the statue of daniel is a hierarchy
it's a golden age a silver age a bronze
age an iron age and at the end of the
iron age we're in the toes where the
toes split into ten so imagine you have
the head at the top you have one at the
top with the crown the golden crown as
the head and then you have the two arms
right and then you have the two arms on
the torso then you keep going down it
keeps it's two and then it ends in
multiplicity it ends in ten toes and the
ten toes are the end of the age the end
of those four ages
and the ten toes are mixture they are
a mixture between
um
between iron and clay and so
you can imagine that as the hierarchy
goes down
the the metal
the metal at the top is the most
precious
the most light
and also the the most shiny you could
say the most incorruptible but also the
least strong in terms of
physical strength it's the weakest it's
the weakest metal
in terms of
you can't make a sword out of uh
out of uh gold right and so as you go
down
the metals are less precious
less uh
less light darker you could say they're
also
they're also uh you know it's harder
and more akin to something like let's
say something like a weapon so as you go
down you get to bronze of course that's
when they made you can start making
swords with bronze
uh and then iron which is the hardest
the strongest of metal but then moving
towards that strong and hard
at some point
it starts to become brittle
so the very process by which you make
something
hard and powerful
if you lose its
flexibility in materiality
and also you lose its unity in terms of
moving towards the crown it's all all
these analogies are playing out together
then you come to
something which is a mixture
and which is multiple
and which is brittle
so those are the toes at the bottom
and so
then you can understand that
out in that situation
an event will happen
right an event which is
let's say a purely natural event
one which is doesn't participate in this
hierarchy of of meaning this hierarchy
of technique this hierarchy of
technology the hierarchy of of meaning
the hierarchy of civilization all of
these things that something will come
from the outside something not made in
the system
and once the system is brittle
it'll smash it
and that's it
right so you can imagine for example
that it could take it could take several
forms you know often it's seen as christ
how christ basically smashed the roman
empire how christ came down and and and
restarted the whole a new a new world
let's say a stone not made of human
hands um purity all of these things and
so
that's what it means you know usually
christ is seen as this stone but you can
understand it as a pattern of a cycle
and how cycle ends you know when it
comes to
to these last moments
yeah
all right
all right so kelly madden asked a
breakthrough in symbolic understanding
happened to me when i sat alone on a
beach and observed i could see land
rising above with water
with square built houses seagulls flying
waves and so forth
i wonder how many people today have ever
seen the stars without light pollution
don't the physical circumstances of
mediated urban life
pose a huge obstacle to our ability to
grasp the ancient worldview
may i experience it may i recommend
these experiences to our community here
yeah you're right you're totally right
you know
uh
the city the city let's say the
the artificial city what it does is it
but it preserves you from the pattern in
in a certain manner not totally but it
it protects you from the the dangerous
aspects of the pattern but it also
isolates you from the
higher aspects let's say
and so
you can imagine you know how in um
you know how in scripture it says at the
end of the times the stars will fall
from the heavens
well there's something about a modern
city that that's what it is right it's
like you can't see the stars in the
heavens anymore and the stars are on the
on the earth
and so the light comes from below and
it's this artificial light that is
lighting up everything but because of it
it's it you can't see the divine
patterns anymore you can't see the the
stable patterns which are in the heavens
and so um
i agree and so going up a mountain you
know like you said sitting on a beach
uh or just going into the ocean
all of these things can be
definitely helpful
in uh in kind of seeing how the world
lays itself out symbolically
all right so
will
asks why pray for the souls
of the dead
and then there's a related question
let's let's
let's answer this one and see if i can
if i end up answering everything
um
[Music]
so the best way to understand that is
that you don't pray for the souls of the
dead
at least not ultimately
there's a there's a manner in which the
at least in the christian story there's
a man in which what christ reveals a
transformation
of death so it's mysterious it doesn't
it doesn't completely make sense in
terms of if you're just paying attention
to the limited temporality but if we if
you listen for example to um the uh
the homily of saint john chrysostom
which we say at easter at pasca every
year
at the end of the homily
it says
hades is empty death is empty christ has
vanquished death death has been
overturned
right death has no power
basically death is gone
and so it's mysterious because it's like
we look around and we see that okay when
people still
die but there's a manner in which christ
has vanquished death and has also in a
certain way transformed the very nature
of death
um
so when we're praying for those that
have fallen asleep in the lord for those
that have
right those
those who have died in the in the
colloquial sense we don't understand
them as being dead we understand them as
being very much alive
and not only alive but also praying if
they are
in christ like if they are in the church
then they're also praying they're
praying for us we're praying for them
uh
in the same way that
that we did in while they were on the
earth right we prayed for them they
prayed for us and we pray for their
salvation they pray for our salvation
um and so we continue to do so
uh after death there's you can
understand it somehow like there is no
there aren't two churches there aren't
two bodies there's only one body
there's only one body of christ and that
body is eschatological
and so all those that
have died before us in christ are alive
in him
and ultimately we will all be together
in him
but through our prayers through our
praying for each other
it participates in us coming together
so
i hope that answers that it's hard i
know it's hard for some people to kind
of understand that and why that
why that's actually a very important
part of the transformation
that christ uh brought about let's say
and the way in which we understand that
all right so jason schweitzer supposedly
it's related let's see what it says i'm
not sure if i'll get this question in
time or not okay um
i've heard there is an idea possibly
within the catholic tradition that one
can pray loved ones out of hell after
they have deceased
uh is 2 samuel 21 10 a symbolic image of
this no not at all if not what purpose
is this
scripture trying to convey i guess my
question might be on symbolism of moving
someone's bones
and so what is it
samuel is that is that the story of the
uh
is that when when
is that when king saul
um
oh no this isn't what i thought it was
i thought it was when uh
all right i don't want to look into this
right now but
let's say in catholic in catholic
tradition uh
you could say
it this way that maybe you can't really
pray someone out of hell you can pray
them out of purgatory i guess that's
probably the best uh
understanding of cat in my understanding
of catholic uh
catholic um
the way the catholics understand it but
i would say that there is a tradition
there is one story
in the ancient church of a church father
i forget which church father it was who
said that he prayed
incessantly for the soul of an of a
pagan emperor and that he was it was
revealed to him that that he
was able to
to basically get him out of hell you
know uh and so
love love covers a multitude of things
and we we need to understand it
we have to always like it's just hard to
talk about this stuff because i i don't
people tend to understand it technically
or understand it like uh
do you have weird ideas about what it is
that we're talking about here what it is
that it means and so
maybe you could ask yourself do you
believe that prayer has an effect on
people's spiritual life
in
the world now
do you think that praying really makes a
difference or not
so do you think that by praying for
someone
you can
affect
their own state
now
if your answer is yes
then it's the same answer for those that
are not in their bodies anymore it's
just the same
but how is that
like
what exactly does that mean
is not
is not super clear so maybe let me let
me say let me try i'm trying to try to
help you guys because it
i'm trying to avoid
this becoming one of those weird things
where we believe things that don't mean
anything anymore right it's like at some
point sometimes when we talk about these
things about life after death and we
talk about
these types of interactions they don't
they don't mean anything to people we
believe them we say them but they don't
mean anything and so
when you pray for someone
right you hold them
in yourself
you're you're remembering them
you are
you are connecting them to you
so you're bringing them
to a certain extent
in communion with you
this has to do with the idea of god
remembering noah or noah remembering god
or jonah remembering god when he was in
the depth of shale like when he was at
the depth of the ocean when he was
basically in death remember that that's
what's going on in that story
and that the memory of god
is what lifted him out the repentance
his repentance and his reconnecting to
god remembering the temple remembering
god is what brought him out of death
and so that is true of god but it's also
true at a lower level for all of us and
the way in which we
we interact with each other
and so by
by
remembering someone in your prayers
you are connecting them to you and to
the extent that you're connected to
others to the extent that you are
connected to god and that those others
are connected to god
that's a real thing
it's a real
binding of people together
and a
kind of dance of prayer
it's the best way i can explain it and
and and i just want to be careful
because i know that like i said
these things can become arbitrary really
fast so i want to be careful that it
doesn't sound arbitrary hopefully this
is a little helpful
to understand so yeah
or maybe i just confused you guys a
whole lot more
sometimes i feel like that especially
during these doing these q a's and i'm
just confusing people more um
all right so mark
says greetings from tbilisi wow cool
i heard you use the word fractal a lot
is dimensional a more accurate word
uh by and by the by that mandel brought
fractal image the zooming into different
repeats only seems to work if the zoom
occurs on the edge of the pattern
and so
um i mean i don't know i'm not sure how
you use the word dimensional i think the
way that we use the word fractal is
really just to help people understand
that it's a
it's a pattern that repeats itself
um
and that is made of itself but it not in
a it's also not in a not necessarily the
mandelbrot uh
let's say fractal is great because it's
uh it's not just a repetition of the
exact same pattern it's almost it is
like a dance where
bigger patterns are made of smaller
patterns which are related to the bigger
patterns but aren't exactly the same and
so you get
this kind of
similarity and difference in different
places the patterns um
and so i agree like obviously if you if
you just zoom into the dark into the
absent part of the mandelbrot
uh pattern you're not gonna
you're just gonna i mean i imagine it'll
be dark for a long time before you
actually encounter something
but i'm not sure what you mean by
dimensional so
all right so enough of the um
symbolic world questions
so one question from the people who
support me on subscribe star
so littlejoe asks hi jonathan i love
your work thank you for your podcast
with bishop baron
to quote john paul ii the church must
breathe with her two lungs
just wondering if you have ever heard of
full metal alchemist brotherhood if not
it is so deeply symbolic i'm sure all of
your followers would appreciate your
analysis of it
and so
it's interesting because like my
daughter my daughter was really into
anime she's not so much into anime
anymore but she was into anime for like
about a year like about like when she
turned a little bit before she turned
13. um
and she really you know we were really
looking for an anime that we could watch
together
uh that wouldn't be because she was
she's smart and she's kind of mature
like that wouldn't be too
they wouldn't be too uh childish but
also not too crazy and so we decided to
watch uh
to watch that series together we watched
a few of the episodes
and uh there's some really in definitely
some interesting stuff in there
definitely some interesting things in
terms of um the idea of like uh
a kind of
a bad incarnation you know this idea of
something that is in a shell that isn't
fully embodied but is kind of this this
arbitrary our most arbitrary
relationship between heaven and earth
and there's also
you know there was this weird episode
about hybrids and stuff that was very
well understood in terms of the
symbolism so yeah so there were some
interesting things but we ended up just
not you just we didn't we just stopped
watching it at some point just because
school started and then everybody's busy
and uh and so yeah but i mean sure maybe
one day i don't really don't watch
anything these days
i tend to
i have waves sometimes i'll watch a few
things and then i just move on there's
so many things to do in life basic right
now there's so many things to do
um
all right so uh so let's now we are
moving on to patreon
all right
so christian swenson asks what is the
symbolism of symbolic thinkers
what role do people like you jonathan
play in the symbolic world what is the
pattern you play out
and so um
it depends it you can depends which way
you could see it like what we hope
is that in a way we are we're acting as
something like uh
we're acting like a crutch
in a way but crutch like you could say
we're acting like garments of skin we're
acting like
a way to help people walk again
but it's also dangerous because
explaining symbolism can get can make
people
can trick people not trick i'm not
trying to trick anybody but can delude
people in thinking that they
that they that they've got it because
they can explain it but explaining it
and living it are not the same and so
and so it's a we're playing a tricky
game where we're kind of walking between
trying to help people have those
intuitions on their own
trying to help people go back to church
in the broad sense of getting you know
re-involved in symbolic worlds um
and explaining it enough so that people
don't just think we're spouting
gibberish you know
so uh
so yeah so so i think that that's the
role
we play
yeah and we hope that we're not ruining
ourselves you know sometimes because you
think like if just explaining it so much
yeah it's dangerous
all right so maximus magiar asks
are objective and subjective useful
terms for talking about reality
well consciousness plays a role in all
manifestation
how about john verveigh's word
transjective
um
that's fine i mean
i use the words i i tend to use those
words a little subversively because i
obviously don't agree
i tend to like i'll tend to for example
want to show that the subjective is
objective in the way that
people think about it kind of in a
vulgar way
you know the idea that because we have
this weird idea that's that somehow the
subjective
is idiosyncratic and the objective is
stable and true
and uh
and it's the problem of this object
subject relationship in in the first
place but like sometimes i play with it
you'll notice that i'll talk about how
this one one's experience is objective
and so it's like it's obviously it's
obviously in a way a misuse of language
but uh
but i think it's because use when you
use if you use a new word like
transjective i'm not sure people will
know what you're talking about and so
you know i think that
if you if you couch it
and you let's say uh accompany it with
other words maybe you know
but i think that that's sometimes like
one of the thing in john's sometimes in
john's descriptions is that he's taken
so much time to really define very
precise words because he he really is
wants to be sure that he's super precise
and uh and so it's extremely useful and
extremely powerful but if you just drop
into it from the outside and you hear
like you know
a good like a good way to understand is
like
go to john vivek's channel and watch you
know like
it's a
episode 50 of the meaning crisis series
and so if you just drop in obviously you
won't
understand anything that he's saying so
it's a build up you know and that has a
lot of value because once you get to the
episode 50 and you know what he's
talking about
you know it's like you can just see how
it all comes together
so so i wouldn't use the word
transaction myself but there are some
words that john uses that i do use ones
that i think that are immediately
available to people that would watch my
video for the first time although yeah i
say that but
i'm sure a lot of people watch my videos
for the first time they're like what is
this guy talking about just complete
complete random i love that i love the
term um
um
like i like relevance realization i like
that term i think it's not that hard for
people to just drop in and understand um
i love the word combinatorial explosion
i think that's an easy word to get so
but there are other terms that he uses
for example uh like
you know when he when he talks about
affordance i think that
requires people to
to kind of dive in and see what it is
that he's talking about and also the
word transjective i think it's not easy
access but it's a good word i mean it's
fine i don't have a problem with it
um
so nathan
condone asks uh hello jonathan
what is the symbolism behind
the saying sins of the father they are
not the responsibility of the son what
of the son who takes on the
responsibility
himself to amend those sins thank you
so
a good way to understand that is that
you could see that the
the sins of the father fall on the sun
and this you could understand it in a
broad sense that you know the actions we
pose they create worlds right they
create bodies and even even if we leave
those programs you could call them
programs let's say a good way to
understand it like you
you create programs and even and even if
let's say you you leave
those programs will run
and they'll run in other people as well
and so someone
i mean the example of like let's say the
son of an alcoholic is a good is a great
it's an easy example to understand but
it applies to so many other things too
so you can you can imagine that a father
an alcoholic father will
those sins
will fall upon the children will affect
them
directly because obviously
you might not have a very good father if
he's an alcoholic but also
certain patterns of behavior will kind
of
will program themselves into the
children and so
you definitely so it can be a good idea
to take on the sins of your father take
on the responsibility of the sins of
your father in the sense that even
though you're not responsible
for the
you're not responsible for those effects
that have appeared on you but if you
take them then you can re-align them
but if you just act as a victim and you
just act as someone who
is a victim of circumstance and has
and and you don't become aware that this
these patterns play out in yourself
then you're going to be there you're
just going to be like a read in the wind
you're just going to you're not going to
be able to uh
to transform that reality so
all right so nick scott says
hi jonathan by the time of this q a
i will be laid off as a result of
medical mandates
i would like to ask you to clarify why
you think
this is not the mark
i'm not trying to suggest you're wrong
or to paint you in a corner just hoping
to better understand what's happening to
me and my family right now it certainly
feels like i've been excluded from
society both directly
no income and indirectly
can't take my kids to a hockey game
without it
thanks for your time and god bless you
and your family
so
so nick i'm sorry to hear of your
situation i'm sorry to hear that you're
going through this and
so maybe let me be clear about this you
know what's happening
is definitely
one
scapegoating
it's definitely
the setup of an authoritarian
system which is creeping in and taking
up more and more space and this
authoritarian system is using
scapegoating as a means to be accepted
by the population
by creating the image of those that
don't want to participate as being the
cause of the problem
this is what's going on now
this is evil it's an it's an evil
we are we are facing with a growing evil
and a growing danger that is true and
that is completely um
it cannot be ignored now
having said that
these things have existed before right
so
authoritarian states
uh scapegoating
ways of identifying people that don't
want that aren't inside
and using them to
ins to
to bring about more and more
authoritarian measures is something
which has happened before
and so
does this does this type of behavior
participate in let's say
beast symbolism yes it does and i've
i've tried to explain this before
especially if you understand
the revelation as a system
as a
as a symbolic structure which reveals
how
society lays itself out how certain
interactions happen you know i've often
talked about how
you know for example weimar from weimar
to the third reich is a moment where the
beast killed the [ __ ] and where these
types of authoritarian measures are
being set up now
so
the reason why i say it's not the it's
not let's say the epitome or the let's
say it's not
completely
this this what's being described in
scripture
is that
at least for now
there is no
direct apostasy
no one's asking you to to to
to let's say to engage in apostasy in
order to be
in order to to get this
and so that's the reason why i'm saying
it's not now i'm not i haven't i've been
vaccinated you know and
because of the authoritarian system
which is setting itself up you know i
definitely intend to
resist as much as i can like resist as
much as my will god god willing is
capable of of of helping me resist but i
also i harbor no ill
thought to those that
did get vaccinated it's like
some people don't perceive what i
perceive they don't perceive that this
is moving into scary territory that that
and also some people
have a different barrier of
a different limit into what it is
what type of authoritarian measures are
acceptable and what which ones aren't
because we we've already seen many
authoritarian measures that we all
participate in you know or that are
moving towards authoritarian measures
that we participate in so
it's like where do you draw the line
where do you decide no it's like this
i'm not going to do
so i think that's up to each of us but i
but i think it's dangerous to say um
i think it's dangerous to say that it's
it's the thing
um
but i think that those who
who act as if it's as if what's going on
is not happening or that it's not a big
deal that we've moved from a
a situation
where freedom was the
where freedom of movement for example
was the basic the the basic right of all
and now we've moved into a system where
basically the the authorities are
allowed to ask for your papers are
allowed to ask you to identify yourself
and um i think that that's a massive
change and those who don't think that
that's a massive change or deluding
themselves you know
if you if you aren't reading for example
okay i suggest people read paul king's
north sub stack he's been doing a great
job at
explaining the the system let's say the
the machine
the modern machine and how it's playing
itself out almost automatically
revealing itself to be what it was even
before covid before all this that it was
already this but now we're seeing let's
say we're seeing the face of it uh more
clearly and so so nick i'm sorry to hear
about what you're going through and i
know
several people here in montreal that are
some people in around the symbolic world
that are dealing with the same kind of
uh
same kind of problem so
yeah so i don't know i don't know i
don't know uh
i can say is uh
say a prayer for you
and hope things don't get worse
matthew f says what is the symbolism of
the roles of prophet priest and king
so
so a good way to understand i mean you
have to you maybe you have to separate
it first of all you can separate it
between something like spiritual
authority
and temporal power
so you can start by having
something like the spiritual authority
above and then temporal power below
the king receives is the king is
anointed
by
the the spiritual
authority
the king finds his legitimacy in
spiritual authority
because the spiritual authority is that
which binds us to a higher purpose
and and by receiving his authority from
a spiritual
his his receiving his role and his crown
let's say from spiritual authority
makes him more than just a thug is the
only way to say it
makes him more than just someone
who uses force to impose his own will on
other people because obviously
states
often
easily rapidly degenerate into that
and so by by receiving his power from
above you could say
it limits that to a certain extent not
completely but it does
now now that now if we look at the
spiritual authority then you can
separate it into
two you could say
and so you the prophet is something like
the direct
authority
and the priest is something like a
mediated authority so the prophet so i
think it's it's really similar to like
left hand and right hand symbolism so
the prophet on the one hand has visions
has
intuitions is you know visited by god
visited by the spirit sometimes that
becomes a little wild things get a
little crazy you know the the the
sometimes even the um
the vision or the experience of god will
manifest its ways in manners which are a
little slightly strangely illegitimate
right think of for example when god
tells ezekiel that he has to cook food
on human human feces it's like sometimes
some of their some of the prophet's
experiences is is
is a little outside of the bounds let's
say uh
and so then you what you need is also
you need another a binding tradition you
need you need something like the priests
which are related to ritual which are
related to law which also are chosen um
[Music]
or have a kind of succession
you know and they have functions clear
functions whereas profits don't
necessarily have clear functions they
can sometimes but often profits are just
they just
like to come down the mountain you know
with the word of god or whatever uh but
that can be super dangerous if it's not
it's not mediated by
by an ecclesiastical hierarchy so an
example of that today is something like
the relationship between monks and
clergy
and so in let's say on monathos there
are a bunch of like
hermits up there and mount athos who
live in caves and
who get visitors and who say things that
are sometimes a little wild and you know
they have these direct intuitions and
you know like what is it that someone
was it was father andrew andrew damick
who uh
was telling us about the naked
aesthetics right that that saint
pauicios talked about how there are
these invisible naked aesthetics that
live up in the in on mount athos and you
know that can manifest themselves and so
it's like that kind of stuff man that's
some intense stuff
um
and i'd say paicios knows these these
naked aesthetics that are that are there
um
and so but so you need something like a
hierarchy of priest in order to moderate
and to mediate
these types of influences um and so of
course the danger with the the priest
and the the the priestly hierarchy is
they can become corrupt it can become uh
somewhat something like a
kind of corrupt bureaucracy um and so
that's why you also need the saints and
you need these more prophetic figures to
to keep it in check you know and so
that's the way to understand that
so dan larabee says why does paganism
necessarily end in human sacrifice
i don't know does paganism necessarily
end in human sacrifice i don't know i
mean it's i don't think necessarily you
know it seems that a lot of human
sacrifice
by the time the christianity came about
even in the roman world for example was
probably all but gone there maybe might
have been some a few examples left but
it was pretty much all but gone seems to
be something which happened
all over the place where human sacrifice
was became moderated by animal sacrifice
and uh
and and other kinds of sacrifices so
if you want to understand human why
human sacrifice
you know
the best thing to to looking at girard
can maybe help you understand that you
know and i'm not sure i'm going to go
into that right now because there's a
lot of
there's a manner in which sacrifice like
ultimately the sacrifice should be human
like no matter how you think about it
you know and you can see that in
the story of abraham
and his son
it's as if there's a sense in which
ultimately the sacrifice
tends towards becoming like let's say
the symbolism of sacrifice tends towards
human sacrifice even though i don't
think that it necessarily happens that
way because i mean pagan culture is
sacrificed animals you know not
necessarily humans um
and that
there's a way in which that somehow has
to be moderated because it's dangerous
like it's a super dangerous thing
and but ultimately that's what happens
in in christ like in christ
it all kind of comes together it all
kind of comes together in the idea of
self-sacrifice
where the problem of human sacrifice
kind of gets resolved in in
in christ you know and
and the martyrs so
think of the martyrs that way think of
the martyrs as willing human sacrifices
sorry think about it that way it's
pretty crazy to think about it but
that's kind of how they were
you know and so you know so
man i can't believe i'm talking about
this
so think about so think about how
ancient cultures practice human
sacrifice
a lot of them like they would for
example they would kill
a child and then they would put the
child
under a post of a building
so the sacrifice of the
human sacrifice would become the
foundation
on which the building would hold so you
can understand it obviously symbolically
as the idea that
human sacrifice is
the the the man in which groups exist
right so you have to
you can't have everything in the group
it doesn't work
and so you have to sacrifice
some aspect
some the best of you
up towards the purpose which binds you
together
then you have to sacrifice the worst of
you
out so you cut off
that which is defective that which is
strange that which is um
that which is not part of the group
and so
that's how it works you know and so
ancient people had a deep intuition that
that's how it works and they engage with
it like
and so
but that's a problem like it's a serious
problem you know uh because it leads to
crazy things like it leads to
escalation right and you you know the
the image that we have for example right
of the
of the aztecs you know that we're you
know killing thousands of people you
know to keep their societies clothing
together because they were in trouble
and they just got to keep killing people
in order to kind of try to consolidate
this thing that was falling apart like
and so chris so christ solves it and so
if you think of this the martyrs as
willing sacrifices
then you can understand why we say
right this the the blood of the martyrs
is the seed of the church they can help
you understand why we place relics under
altars especially relics of martyrs
it can help you understand why martyrs
we found churches on the the place where
martyrs died
man i can't believe i'm saying this
sorry guys
oh boy all right okay
like every every q a i do i figure one
day i'm to say something
all right okay so mid
mid muhammad ali says hi jonathan
why does the christian story only have
white skin complexion characters
including the angels what advice would
you give a muslim black man
who resonates with orthodox teachings
and looking to convert orthodox
christianity i asked because after going
to an orthodox church for the first time
and seeing the icons
i started to question whether the
christian story was really my story help
thanks
so much
i think that i think that
for the first thing to understand is
to understand
that
a lot of a lot of the way of in which
people represented of course uh christ
and the um
has to do with just the reality of the
historical moment you know and so
orthodox you know christianity became
roman very fast and so it became roman
in all of its
representations
but if you look for example at
representations of the syrian
images of christ and the syrian
tradition they're not exactly the same
as the representation in the roman
tradition their differences in the way
they're portrayed also because you know
we just people didn't think about it in
that term like a lot of these skin color
tropes
the way that we think about them now in
terms of of the whole history of racism
and the whole history of race in
in
in um
especially in the modern world and
slavery and all that stuff it's just
it's we have to be careful not to
project that back
into the ancient world
now
that's one thing
um
the one thing that can maybe help you
which maybe is not exactly the same as a
skin color question
um but you can help you understand that
christianity always has an aspect of the
strange included in it which is that
for the romans
christ was not a roman
and so they understood that there was an
element of christ which was not just
their own
like thing
and that that was actually part of the
story part of the story was engaging
with something which was not just my
thing
um
and so i know that might be this might
be hard uh
maybe hard for you but maybe that's the
way to go about it is to understand that
just in a certain manner just like the
way in which
um
[Music]
the way in which uh christianity came
from
israel into rome right in the same way
the christianity that you're
encountering probably comes from rome to
you
and so it will appear
as somewhat as roman
and it's better to think of it that way
rather than to think of it in terms of
skin color now
if you if you look at ethiopian
christianity you'll notice that the way
christ is represented it's very
different from the way that the greeks
represent uh christ and the way the
romans represent christ and the the way
you know if you look at like i said
syrian images you'll see like christ has
kind of almost like a more um
his the eyes are more like almonds you
know like there's just different traits
that people would just intuitively put
into christ we have to be careful not to
be excessive about it because it's
dangerous it's dangerous to consciously
try to
make christ into the image of what we
are because that's a little dangerous
but there is it will
it will subtly appear now
there's some interesting things like
there's some interesting things
for example like if you look at um
nubian christianity which at some point
disappeared
when uh then when most of nubia
converted to islam or was invaded by
islam or whatever um you can see that
the way that they represent themselves
and the way that they represent christ
is different and so if you find old
frescoes of nubian churches you'll see
that they they represent themselves as
darker
than uh than christ but in ethiopia i've
had some crazy discussions with people
like just accidentally about that where
the ethiopians perceive themselves as
being very much the same as christ in
terms of the way they look
um
but they also perceive themselves the
ethiopian christians a lot of them as
not actually being african which it's
just weird it's weird how fractal a lot
of these things are you know um so
so i wish i could help you more you know
but i think that it's it's important to
understand that we
that that there is an aspect of
christianity which will always be
uh strange to us that will always be
something else and so when i as a
frenchman encounter an icon of christ i
know i'm looking at a jew i'm not
looking at a
at a european you know and so that's
important to understand that and even
though it doesn't appear
let's say in the actual let's say the
the pigmentation of the color of the
skin it's nonetheless part of how we
encounter christ so
hope that's good enough uh
hope that helps you
but if you're interested like look i'll
be honest with you like if you're
interested
in thinking about this differently and
exploring this there is a really
wonderful group
called the the brotherhood of saint
moses the black in the united states um
that are mostly antiochian christians
and a lot of uh people who had
you know
uh you know the
experience of being uh being black and
living in america
and so there are some amazing priests
father moses barry was just like a
living saint to be honest and father
turbo calls who i keep
telling i keep telling myself i'm gonna
have him on the channel and then just
life moves moves quickly but i might
have father turbo on my channel soon so
there's someone you might some people
you might want to look into
um
and they've done some interesting work
in terms of exploring the symbolism of
darkness
i read some of their um
some of their prayers that they did and
some of the articles that were published
on their website and there was some
interesting things going on where
they're also trying to show
the positive aspect of darkness in the
old testament right the idea of the dark
glory of god and the idea of the queen
of the south and uh you know how christ
says the queen of the south will rise up
and judge this generation like there's
all of this interesting symbolism
which is there you can look also in our
universal history series we did a whole
thing about how there's a are greek
greek traditions of how
the the final emperor will rise out of
ethiopia so it's not as simple as we
want to think and so i although i
understand you struggle i would say
there's there's a lot of there's a lot
of things to think about uh
beyond that as well so hope that helps
all right
so dusan babic asks why silver hurts
monsters
um
it doesn't hurt every monster right it
hurts werewolves and uh
vampires maybe i'm not sure but for sure
werewolves um
and i think it has to do with purity
you know i think it has to do with
a light light impurity you know like the
silver is is uh is is so shiny and and
and light so i think that's what it has
to do it's kind of like
say it's like
like a silver bullet right like a light
bullet of light that
shoots and uh
dispels the monster
so chase and lindsey asked is the
relationship between demons and humans a
cosmic version of the relationship
between cain
and abel
is this why um fallen angels are so
connected to kane's lineage if not why
do demons seem to hate humanity so much
um
maybe yeah for sure like this is a good
way to see it like there are some
strains or some traditions for example
that talk about how
demons or the demons that fell it's
because they were jealous of humans and
the special place that humans played
um
and so
so yeah so it's a good it's a maybe it
is a good way of thinking it of thinking
about it
and so why do humans demons seek to hate
seem to hate humanity so much it's
it's i think it's mostly the idea that
they want to enslave us
right that there are patterns
of being and beings that have that let's
say
that manifest certain
certain idolatrous patterns that they
want us to fall into so that we
follow them right so that we worship
them
and so it's basically
you can understand it as beings that
embody certain patterns that are looking
to be worshipped instead of god so a
jealousy to god and jealousy towards men
where men are meant to ultimately let's
say rise up beyond the angels would we
say of the mother of god more glorious
be uncompared than the seraphim right
more she's higher than the seraphim
higher than the cherubim she's higher
than all the angels and so humanity is
meant to be above the angels ultimately
there's a mystery about that by the way
there's a mystery about that even in
terms of things like cognitive science
and in terms of understanding the man in
which identities exist through embodied
intelligence all of this is is not it's
not arbitrary right none of this is
arbitrary
so um
so maybe that helped a little bit
so white lawrence what is the symbolism
of the great pyramids of giza
um i think i think
i think that i've said i've said uh on
my uh that egyptology is a certifiable
disease i think so i think egyptology is
just mostly egypt symbolism is just
complete
like it's just complete nonsense but you
know you can understand uh the symbolism
of pyramids in general that is it's
basically a mountain it's just a
mountain
it's a symbolism of a mountain it's a
triangle it's a mountain it's a like a
ziggurat it's like uh
so that's really what the symbolism of
uh
of those of pyramids are
and so they're a symbolism of the manner
in which
let's say the transcendent
heaven meets earth and then
comes down into the world but you know
it's like i don't really know what those
pyramids are for in terms of a more
specific and i think a lot of people
speculate and i think probably most
people don't really understand much
about egypt's
egyptian symbolism it's just lost and
it's just speculation to be honest
you know and i mean just because they
translated the hieroglyph doesn't mean
they understand what's going on there so
i mean it's interesting to see something
sometimes you see parallels and he's
like oh it's interesting but i really
wouldn't spend much time on egyptian
symbolism if i were you guys
jeff dunlop asked what is the meaning of
the moon landing
what is the redemption of
wernher von braun
or a continuation of the nazi the nazi
worldview
you mean when ron brown that's the guy
who joined nasa is that is that what it
is
yeah well let me just see this yeah okay
yeah so he's the he's the nazi that
became um that became a uh
became
um i mean what is the meaning of the
moon landing
it's the mean
you could the meaning of the moon
landing is basically the uh
disenchantment
like the
the
the highest point of disenchantment of
the world would be something like the
moon landing where
it gives you the sense that none of this
means anything like none of these none
of these lights up there mean anything
that none of this
has any you know it's like it's a it's a
form of it's a form of alienation it's
like the ultimate alienation you know
and it's
think of it like this think of it like
it's the it's this success
in disembodying self from your
experience
and perceiving the world from a
completely alien point of view
um and then
that having the fruit of
basically destructuring
the world like of
acts as a way to to destroy the world um
and so in terms of
vernon van brown or whatever that kind
of stuff i don't know man i
mean are too many crazy stories about
that
i mean you could say like it's
it's about power a lot of this stuff is
just about power
all right
all right josh
um you've talked about the subject of
piercings i've had my own thoughts on
how christ was pierced through both
hands his feet side and then thorns on
his head and by flogging but it seems
there's a greater picture
of how all of these piercings are
completion
or fulfillment in a lot of ways
uh can you expound
yeah
yeah
this stuff you guys this stuff is hard
to talk about the piercing thing
like the last i think it's on the last q
a that i ended up talking about
piercings and uh
the kind of subject that you regret
talking about as soon as you've talked
about it but
let me just give you a few hints about
how the story of christ is just so
completely
crazy like crazy in the sense that it
just contains everything and so
so there's this whole symbolism of
christ being
being
pierced in the sense that he becomes the
new source of the world and so blood and
water flows from the side
you know
the wounds the wounds symbolism of the
wounds of christ you know the
i talked about this i talked about
shaman allah says vulnerary uh of christ
but there's also a manner in which
christ is also fixed
to the cross
and so it's like the the wound the wound
becomes both a symbolism of this opening
up of a new world
but at the same time it's like the
fixing of something
man
that stuff's hard to
think about the crucifixion is one of
the hardest things you'll ever do
all right
reuben korff asks hi jonathan looking
forward to god's dog
i've been listening with great interest
as we all have your account of universal
history with richard however i'm
wondering whether in your discussion of
the symbolism of constantinople you
stray into the pattern of revolution
i.e you say that the converted rome is
constantinople rather than christian
rome itself
this ultimately ignores and reduces to
the margin the source of the meaning for
constantinople
founding found in the title the new rome
if i misunderstood something here
i'm trying to understand what you mean
okay so you say that the converted rome
is constantinople rather than christian
rome itself
so i'm not sure there's a dif what's the
difference between those two i'm not
sure i understand it this opening doors
it reduces to the margin the source of
the meaning
so i think i think constantinople was
the christian rome that is it was a
refounding of a new rome
under the christian banner so it's
basically
a baptized version of rome
is the way to understand
constantinople
so
so i'm not sure i totally understand why
this is the pattern of revolution
um
yeah sorry i wish i don't totally
understand the question i wish i did
i might just be late too
it's not that late actually but some of
those questions some of your questions
guys just crazy doozies
all right dean parker asked look at this
question dean what are you
doing was there anything symbolic about
the 1980s satanic panic particularly for
those that were false accused of heinous
crimes
do you think a similar pattern might
repeat
um
i don't know i don't think so i don't
think that that that um that a similar
pattern will repeat
and uh
i think that
i think i think that you
the the the satanic panic
just like a lot of these things a lot of
so you can understand okay so think
about the people
in in the most common sense
right in the most
basic like the the regular joe six-pack
like whatever the most common type of
person you can imagine
and so you have to understand these
those people as
the
the building block like the building
block from below of of society
right the the peasants
the
and so they actually
from below hold the world together okay
and so the people that are down here
they don't understand they're not
they're not the smartest people but
they're the most embodied people that's
why there's a sense in which
peasants don't go to hell right it's
like
intellectuals go to hell and and uh and
priests and bishops go to hell if you
look at images of um
of hell in the middle in the middle ages
it's like the peasants they'll go to
hell it's all the monks and the priests
and the bishops and the kings they go to
hell um
but what i mean is that is that there's
a sense in which
they're they're they're very embodied
and so
sometimes things get
starts to shake up
and the the the the slower part of
reality is like uh
rings an alarm bell
and they're into they're kind of
embodying or intuiting or
noticing a change and it's very
unconscious and so they start to ring
the bell and when they ring the bell
things start to manifest themselves in a
weird way
and so
so the the satanic panic
as much as the witch uh craze that
happened you know in the
in the late
in the early um enlightenment and you
know around that time
it's the marker of a transformation
so
you have to look at the way things are
described not necessarily as just
descriptions of events in a very
discreet way or a very concrete way but
rather as something which is happening
and so it's like the satanic panic or
the
the satanic change
did happen
in the late 70s and 80s
like there really was a train like there
really is a there really was these
changes happening in culture which were
which were taking christianity out of
the center of cultural discourse and
putting in
something which was
satanic in a broad sense which was about
the passions which was about greed which
was about all the all these things which
are it was about self
aggrandizing all of this stuff was there
so then this this manifests itself in
like um
almost in a story literary imagery and
all this imagery which kind of pops up
and so you could think that someone
let's say
so
you know it has to it's similar to what
you see with this travis scott thing you
know i'm probably going to make a video
about that maybe a patron only video
just because i want to go into it too
much in public but it's like uh
there's certain imagery that are related
to certain behaviors
and that just happens
and so kind of satanic imagery
is related to passions and is related to
obsession with things that
are what they are so
i don't know if this makes sense and so
it's like so like the people that the
satanic panic in the 80s
although it went it became like a kind
of uh
kind of hysteria
was nonetheless manifesting something
that was happening in the in the culture
in the basic culture a change that was
happening
and so i think that that's how you have
to look at a lot of these this stuff now
is that you don't have to believe in the
in the like the
in the the way that the conspiracy
theories and all these things the way
that they're described in their concrete
so like think about it like a good
example is like lizard people right like
lizard men you know the people who think
that they're lizard men that are ruling
the world and everything it's like
you don't have to think that they're
like
genetically lizard people that are
ruling the world to understand what
these tropes are
referring to or what these tropes are
ringing the bell about
right this intuition
that there's something
corrupt in the hierarchy structure and
that there's something about
there's a sense in which there are
certain hands that are moving things
around not that aren't doing it for our
are good that are only acting for the
good of something else for a strange
good you could say
and so
all right anyways i hope you guys
understand what i mean
um
i'm not saying there aren't like actual
people who worship the devil there are
there definitely are for sure there are
everything exists um
but i think the panic part is
all right sorry
so walrus king 16 says hi jonathan it's
daylight savings a little 666 god that's
i don't i don't know
i don't think i understand what you mean
by that uh
is daylight savings a little 666.
uh like in a sense maybe like in the
sense of a system that tries to
impose itself
like on the natural patterns of the
world and change them almost kind of
arbitrarily maybe i don't know it's a
bit of a stretch to to connect those two
together
alright so patrick moore says
what is the symbolism of torture and
mind control
example mk ultra
man
what if a community who consciously
takes part in torture and mind control
of an innocent person
and in the process destroy that society
i i'm not sure i understand your
question what do you mean and in the
process destroy that society
i mean there's nothing like mk ultra is
just evil like and mk ultra is an
example okay so let's say this way so
people are going to freak out when i say
this all right so like
because you're not gonna you're not
gonna you're not gonna some people are
not gonna understand what i'm about to
say i'll say it you know like mk ultra
is an example
of the lizard people
that are acting
that have infiltrated power and are
acting in the world all right let's
unpack that
it's like
mk ultra is an example of evil
forces
that were able to infiltrate
the secret parts of
of our govern governing structure
and were able
to do horrible things to their own
population
in order to make themselves more
powerful
do you see what i'm trying to do here
like do you see where i'm trying to
bridge the story verse
and what's happening and so
hopefully that makes sense to you guys
hopefully you understand what i'm
talking about
and i won't people won't clip this and
say jonathan believes in the in the
lizard people
man
all right nina morris ask is maui from
moana saint christopher
um
[Music]
i know i don't think so i mean maybe
kind of i don't know
because he carries her across the waters
kinda i guess yeah i hadn't thought
about that maybe maybe
all right
man how many questions are left here i'm
running out of i'm running out of breath
here
all right i need to go a little faster
janet horseman
um when you use the word eschaton do you
mean the same thing as the phrase age to
come that jesus and paul use also when
jesus says whoever believes in him will
not perish but have eternal life what
does he mean by eternal life i always
thought it meant unending time that
would occur in the age to come but now
since listening to some of your content
i understand he turned into something
separate from time
do you think our resurrected bodies will
inhabit both time and eternity like
jesus resurrected body seems to
so i understand the word eschaton as the
age of ages
the age of ages is a good way to
understand it because that's what we say
in our in our prayers until the ages of
ages
that is
say just like
let's say eternity is like the
something like the the time of time
or the heaven of heavens
right and so the age of ages
is a place in which all ages culminate
into one
i don't know how to tell you and so
that's what the eschaton is it's the
totality of everything
brought together
so the totality of all the ages totality
of all of time brought together
that's that's the the eschaton
and eternity is something like that in
terms of
but not exactly the same
eternity is
eschaton the eternity seems to be even
more than that than just eschaton
because eschaton seems to be like take
let's say you take
all of all of time in all society and
then it comes to its end and when it
comes to its end it like reveals
the meaning of everything
the re the meaning and the the totality
of all that happened until then it's
like a
kind of like um
that's why it's a judgment you know and
so
you could say that
you know when you you play uh
let's say
you play a football game and then when
the football game ends
then you understand
and you know
the consequences and the fruits of all
the actions that were taken during the
football game
so while the football game is going on
you see the players playing
but you don't know what the fruits of
those actions and those interactions are
going to be you only know the fruits of
that at the end so the end becomes a
light by which we look back and we see
all of what happened before
and so it judges all that what that all
and it gives and it reveals the purpose
of all of that which happened before and
so imagine something like that
but for
everything
all right this is as good as i'm gonna
get also i'm getting tired
all right so brad holcomb says hey
jonathan i really appreciate all your
work i wanted to ask what the mandurah
almond symbolizes i know it surrounds
christ in the transfiguration icon
is it the coming together of opposites
heaven spirit and earth matter i think
it also relates to the vesica piscus
pisses and the fish symbol
yeah i've had some people
tell me that there's definitely a
relationship between the vesque pisces
and the fish symbol in ways that i that
i didn't totally uh get you know until
this is a priest which uh the name
father
i'm sorry father that i philip father
philip father philip cantos yes he's the
one who told me about this he said if
you look at an image of the at anastasis
sometimes christ is standing on the
doors of hades
and the doors of hades the way they're
placed they often act as the
they act as the the tail of the fish
like you have this fish and it creates
the fish and i was like man i need to
think about that more sadly i didn't
think about it more but for sure that's
that image amendora
is the only image the only possible
image that only has two sides
so it's it's probably the best way to
understand uh
understand uh
that the that image the mandola or the
almond
yeah
and so you know some people have seen
feminine symbolism in that that image
and it's possible that it's there it's
not completely
um i don't think it would be completely
arbitrary to think that it's it's
somewhat
in that symbolism as well
but mandorelos are aren't always almond
shapes sometimes they have other shapes
but the almond-shaped mandurala
um seems to have something and it also
seems to have something to do with like
yeah like the union of opposites is
probably the best way of understanding
that i think
all right so daniella
pearl roth says
while the kyle rittenhouse trial
supervisor in the u.s can't help
thinking about pontius pilate and the
show trial that convicted christ and led
to appeasement of the mob
this must be a very old symbolic pattern
can you talk about the symbolic meaning
behind this pattern of trials thanks
so i'm not going to comment on your
american politics guys i'm not american
but
the the idea of a trial especially a
public trial that
is
serving a form of sacrifice is maybe
the way to understand that
and so you you can understand
how
the mob
or the people
they are looking
right
they're looking for a way to to um
to appease their
their anger or to appease the sense
in which this person is responsible for
all their
all their problems becomes an image
becomes a totem right of all
the problems and so they project all the
sins into that person and then that's
when the trial can become something like
a show trial and that the person
the judge or whatever who's in charge of
the trial will want to give that
person as a sacrifice to the mob to
appease them because
yeah it's a scapegoat situation and
that's what happened with christ
and that's what happens usually in show
trials
all right norm grande says
he starts by saying this is obviously
too big to fully delve into a q a all
right norm thanks man
but i wonder if you can touch upon the
somali relationship between the
transfiguration the resurrection and the
ascension
is each a small fractal of what follows
or maybe how the role of light plays
into each
um
yeah definitely i mean definitely the
transfiguration the resurrection and the
ascension are really something like
um they're really something like uh
fractal
images of each other and that they kind
of contain each other or they help us
understand each other you could say and
so there's a way in which you could
understand that
the
the ascension is there is something like
a transfiguration
right and the resurrection is already
we're already the beginning of the
ascension
um
and that
the resurrection of christ manifested
the meaning of the transfiguration so
actually i think a good way to see it is
that way is to say to see how
they each cast a light on each other and
so you if you try to unders if you
understand all three
looking at each other you'll have a
better
sense of what's going on and what is the
ultimate
purpose of the incarnation we could say
all right so dorothea asked in our
church marriage preparation programs
people have been telling engaged couples
to always put their spouses first in a
marriage and their child second while i
get where this is coming from it still
doesn't sound right what are your
thoughts
um
people probably say that because that
that um
that that some people that naturally
there's a tendency to do the opposite
let's say especially i think mostly
women i think mostly women tend to
immediately want to put their child uh
first um
but
but so that's why they need to
consciously try to put their spouse
first
and this is
important because it creates the proper
relationship
of
of hierarchy between the children and
the the parents and it also models a
relationship
you know and so
it also models the manner in which
the couple exists together and so that's
better because the child
will
see a a model of a couple so that when
that child grows up then they will be
able to reproduce it but if if let's say
the mother puts their children ahead of
the father
then
then that child will not be able to
properly engage in a
in a healthy relationship when they're
older
all right so anders
uh so anders of ralstrad said hi
jonathan paul recently did a commentary
about your interview with ben hadkie the
video left me wondering how you would
distinguish between an angel of
principality and a spirit
um
so maybe this can give me the
opportunity to say that by the way like
there was some misunderstanding and like
i really enjoyed paul's video because he
really helped me to brief to think of
certain things like to phrase something
the proper way but i think there was a
general misunderstanding about ben which
is that ben is actually uh catholic like
ben is not just a like an
atheist materialist he's actually uh
someone who grew up in a very catholic
world and went to a uh very tamistic
college so he actually grew up with a
lot of um
a lot of catholicism and is very
knowledgeable about catholicism now i
think that for sure it was clear in the
interview that you could see that ben is
questioning his faith that he's
struggling with some elements of of
christianity but he wasn't just like
just like a like a kind of uh atheist
materialist the way some people
perceived it so
that's one second of all is that
so angel principality and spirit
they're related to each other right
they're they're they're related to each
other but you can understand that
they're there's something like in a
so you could say that angels and
principalities are spirits
um
and that
principality describes the type of
spirit that is
a uh that is the head of bodies
that is the head of certain
realities so it's a principle right it's
a it's the principality of uh
of an aspect of reality right and so
angel usually means messenger and so
in general
so the angel is
is that which carries that which is
above down lower to to that which is
below and then carries that which is
below back up above you could say so the
angel moves back and forth between
heaven and earth you can
understand it
between like jacob when he sees the
angels going up and down the ladder of
of of reality
um and so but then these can be
interchangeable right because you could
say that prince a principality is is an
angel because
if it's a proper if it's a if it's a
proper principality then it's that it's
in manifesting a higher the let's say
the higher will into lower aspects of
reality by being subject to god and
being let's say the
the angel of uh of this city or this
aspect of the reality then it's acting
like an angel because it's
it's bringing
the will of god down to a lower level
it's it's communicating it and bringing
it down to a lower level
and so
that's the best way that i can help you
understand it so to a certain extent
some of these terms are interchangeable
but they can also be used more precisely
if we want to if we want to uh to talk
about specific things and so you let's
say you have a spirit there's an aspect
of you that is spirit that is invisible
that is pattern that is all these things
um and you also
to a certain extent act as a
principality in a lower way but maybe
not in a cosmic way and you also
are an angel can be an angel
you know sometimes the angels in
scripture
it just means messenger so you can also
be an angel of god
but maybe not in a cosmic way at least
not yet and so maybe in a more local way
hopefully that helps to understand
it's the best i can do with that
um
all right so garrett witner says hello
jonathan forgive me for the fullest
question but does jesus
ruling at his father's right hand imply
equality
and so forgive me uh from what position
is the theotokos granted to rule if i'm
in any way onto something
would this be best not to discuss if i'm
not could you perhaps tell me what my
error is
um
so being on the right hand implies
uh
it implies a hierarchy of function at
least
and so the idea that christ is at the
right hand of the father implies that
there is a
not necessarily a hierarchy of nature
because that's important not to to have
that in the trinity but there is
definitely a hierarchy of function
and so the right hand is
something like
the surrogate of the center that's the
best way to understand it actually if
you understand that you'll understand a
lot of stuff about right hand symbolism
um and so the right hand because the
right hand is that which
let's say
tens brings towards let's say bring
towards
himself when you you the right hand is
that by which you act deliberately in
the world and and you bring it towards
you let's say um
it also becomes a surrogate of of the
center so the right hand man will be
something like you can understand it
like
like my right hand man is the one who
represents me when i'm not there
that's the way to understand it and so
that's why for example the idea like of
saint peter
uh
being on the right of christ and also
being seen
as you know the pro that has a certain
primacy
um
and you can understand that's why for
example if you look at i and there are
different ways to think about it but if
you look at icons of let's say the
ascension the mother of god will be in
the center
right but
if you have
her direct relationship with christ
you'll be on his right hand
so that's way to understand that in
terms of right hand symbolism you'll
understand you'll see
like i said if you understand that
you'll you'll understand a lot of stuff
about about about right hand symbolism
and also
if you don't get that sometimes you'll
be confused at why
certain figures are on the right and
then on the in the center and other
images
all right so benjamin kincaid says hi
jonathan i was wondering why crowns are
associated with royalty and their
symbolic value understand that it
probably has to do with the value of
precious metals adorned above the queen
but why didn't we sympathize empathize
emphasize valuable pendants over the
heart
as the primary symbol of royalty
because the crown is glory
so a crown is the man in which you
participate in something which is beyond
yourself
so that's what
that's what glory is also it's like it's
it's it's an extension
of you
that's not you that's kind of added to
you
what makes you participate in something
higher
so that's why the crown comes from
heaven right god gives you a crown from
heaven that's why
that's why um
samuel pours the oil down on the head
the shiny stuff he pours the shiny stuff
from above
um
and so um
yeah that's the best way to understand
it so think of uh think of anointing
for example as
putting shiny stuff on your head
as
like a pointing like
that separates you from the crowd it
pulls you up
and then pulling you up right it it both
you're both held you both hold the the
so the king but holds the kingdom
together
but ultimately has to do it in the name
of something which is beyond him or else
why would people join together under him
they might do so for let's say
suspicious reasons like getting loot or
getting
you know accumulating stuff
but but if you want something that is
more noble then you need that
that movement up
all right so marcus david why does
someone who follows christ needed to get
baptized in order to officially
considered part of the church i don't
see the need for it what exactly is it
that baptism does
so christianity is a participative
religion it's a ritualized participative
religion despite what some of our
christian friends want to believe you
know it has sacraments and
sacramentality is a manner in which
we are bound to that which is above and
we receive from above and then we also
we also uh
let's say
embody the participation that which is
above and so baptism
is a form of washing you know it's a
form of dying to your old self in order
to become a new creature so it's a
transition between an old world and a
new world it's a transition between
yeah and so
i don't know how else to say it you know
i mean it's a lot of other stuff but
it's that's that's what it is and so but
you have to you have to manifest that
you have to
you have to manifest the transition
between two worlds like it has to it has
to actually be
be
real it can't be
just
uh yeah so so
i don't know how else to explain it's
like any ritual
it's it's obviously it's not like any
ritual the sacraments are not like any
ritual but the only way to approach them
if you don't understand them is to think
of more lower rituals that can help you
kind of get it and so
um
so you could say something like let me
say let me let me tell you let me let me
bring about a situation for you that can
help you understand it's like
you could say
if i'm going to if i'm going to talk to
someone
if i'm going to come up to someone and
talk to them like why do i need to
shake their hand like why do i need to
look at them in the eye
why do i need to stand in front of them
right and so
he's like because all those things he's
like why i don't i don't see the need
for it i don't i don't want to do those
things i want to i want to encounter the
person so why do i have to do these
types why do i have to do these kinds of
things why do i have to acknowledge them
you know by saying hello why do i have
to so it's like
these methods like these embodiments are
the manner in which we enter into
relation with someone so the sacraments
are the formal man the formal ways
in which we enter into relationship with
each other and with christ in the church
to me it's not it's it's
those things exist for a lot of stuff
all right you know it's like those
things exist for many many
participations that you'll have
hope that helps i don't know i hope it
helps i don't know if it does
also towards the end of these i always
get a little rambly
all right so alyssa says hi jonathan
could you please help me to understand
how to conduct myself in the current
situation
man
the imposition of control over private
life and body around the world it
terrifies me to death
as the events unfold and i'm not sure i
could withstand if it things got
complete go completely downhill i was
thinking of attending the walks but
something within me is uneasy with this
idea and after watching your video
on the two headed serpent of discourse
i'm thinking
i think i'm thinking in a wrong
direction i don't know what else i could
do to make any difference
i think
i think this i mean i think
different people play different roles in
these situations and i think
i think that being attentive to to to
yourself and being attentive to what you
think you need to do
is better than any
answer that i'm gonna give you because
um
yeah
i wish i had a simple answer to give you
i don't know
i think the ultimately
it's possible that the best
the best um way to deal with a
authoritarian situation
is to
resist and accept the consequences
that seems to me to be
the most christian path but i don't
think it
i don't think it's it does it doesn't
mean that everybody has to do that
yeah i don't think everybody has to do
that
all right so daniel townhead says
dear jonathan why do some contradictions
seems to be or point to a higher form of
truth while others seem to show
hypocrisy or to discredit anything
relying on the contradiction
um
it's a good question
and so
the reason why some contradiction seems
to point to a higher form of truth
is
that
reality is beyond the is beyond what we
can say
so sometimes there's a manner in which
you can
show two aspects of reality which seems
to be contradictory which ultimately
point to a higher truth
um
and so
the difference between
one and the other
is that usually
the contradiction which points to
hypocrisy
is
usually has a ulterior motive
it's usually weaponized it's usually
um
you can if you're careful you can
discern
the power that is that is trying people
are trying to
get
by engaging these types of
contradictions um
yeah that it's utilitarian
so it's a lie basically
and a hypocrisy
whereas the contradictions which reveal
higher mysteries
um will usually appear free from these
types of
these types of um
utilitarian goals
so
hopefully that helps
so drew mcmahon asked he recently talked
about monsters being something we might
use to fight off other monsters
does this seem to align more with jung's
idea of integrating the shadow rather
than the christian idea of removing it
all together
or do i not have the correct
understanding here
thank you so
so much okay so
monsters are just things that are that
are ill-defined like monsters are not
necessarily moral uh in themselves their
chaos their potential their ill-defined
categories you know they're not moral
now the problem
the problem
with jung's notion of integrating the
shadow is it seems to me like it's it
seems to me that he tends to give
substance to darkness like he tends to
give being
to not to non-being
and and
so i think
so for example a christian will say
something
like be aware of your
shadow like be aware of your darkness be
aware of your of your death like stay
aware of those things
um
but it seems like jung's idea is more
like you need to
become conscious of your worst
of your worst uh
aspects
and then integrate them into your person
but
again it's always the problem of seeing
darkness
um
instead of transforming that darkness
into something good so let me give you
an example so
so in christianity would say things like
everything that exists necessarily
points to a good because for it to exist
it has to point to a good
and so we can say that all our passions
are good and they need to be turned
towards the good in order for them to
reach their own fullness so
let's say
like even something like uh you know
can i say this
you know like let's say your
your desires for sexuality your desires
for food these can be turned
right towards something which will bring
you
would transform you spiritually so what
jung seems to to say is something i mean
this is i'm not a union but with what i
encounter it's more like you know you
have all these dark fantasies
and you need to
integrate them
in order
to be full but it's like okay
that to me that that is very different
from the idea of you have all these
desires
and you need to be able to
let's say turn them towards the good
so that then they become full because
because if because if they're just dark
then they they're actually like
fragments
it's not that they're that have they
have body in themselves that they're
they're like they're like
ligaments or like they're strands of
things which that that don't connect
so i mean that's the way that i see it
but
all right so scotty thorpe asked hey
jonathan the book the cloud of unknowing
we're taught about two realms in
centering prayer called the cloud of
forgetting beneath us and the cloud of
unknowing above us
he described this concept in our
symbolic world view thanks
so yeah that's i mean i've talked about
this before that the idea that there's a
manner in which i talked about this
recently actually in the jordan peterson
um video the one the the symbolic world
one that he put up where there's a man
in which identity
above identity is something like uh
unknowing
in the sense that it's i self-sacrifice
or it's kinetic like identity empties
itself above
you know it so you have to give yourself
to something above you
in order for your identity to have any
value so it's like the highest point of
identity is something like sacrifice of
of of identity sacrifice of knowledge
sacrifice of
of gnosis in even in the in that sense
where
above knowledge is unknowing
now below
there's another darkness which is also a
breakdown of identity which is
forgetting
right which is which is not being
connected being disconnected so let's
say
jonah at the bottom of the whale
forgot god like was forgotten by god or
forgot god
and he had to remember god in order to
be reconnected to god
but then there's also a sense in which
above that
giving himself to god would be something
like
a sacrifice of himself into that higher
state and so they're all they're
opposites now it's it's really important
because
a lot of people today super subversive
people will try to trick you in thinking
one is the other
and so we'll try to connect let's say
well i'm telling you it's going to
happen more and more well try to connect
something like hybridity
strangeness
fluid identity
with
divine unknowing
i'm telling you if you haven't
encountered it yet you're going to
encounter it pretty soon he might even
encounter it coming out of some churches
um and so that's the deep confusion it's
a it's the deepest
it's the deepest confusion
um
so watch out for that stuff
all right so we're almost done here
conor says i find this scene in genesis
15 where adam brings all the animals to
be cut in half very interesting but i
don't know what to make of it he brings
a heifer a female goat or ram
all three years old a turtle dove and a
young pigeon
um the land animals are cut in half and
the birds are not when the sun goes down
there was a flame and behold there
appeared a smoking oven and lamps of
fire that passed between those divided
pieces could you explain these passages
um
yeah i mean
kinda i
met you would probably be better at
explaining this
so you can understand that it has to do
like think about it in terms of
of body and light or body and spirit and
so
it's like uh you create a body
and then
there's a the flame like let's say the
flame
manifests itself emits that body
i don't know how else to say it like i
don't know how to explain it um
so the the the the light is in the
center of the dead of the death like the
the
the spark appears
in the carcass like the spark so it's
like uh it's like honey found in the
body of the deadline or
um you know it's like christ moving down
into hades it's
it's um so i'm just going to give you
analogies because i'm not going to
explain this to you
um
yeah i think that that's probably the
best way if i if you think of those
analogies that i just gave you maybe it
can give you the intuition you need to
to uh to understand that
all right
all right so
stephen osborne
you could i think it's maybe because
we've done so many of these q as like
all your questions are becoming more and
more and it's becoming harder and harder
man i mean good question though it's a
great question just harder
uh stephen osborne john vicki's
relevance realization requires a top
down bottomless simultaneous
simultaneity to work so why not
characterize this
as us and dwelling angels and angels
indwelling us
um yeah i mean something like that so
you know swede say maximus dude sam
maximus it's awesome about this you know
and so it's it's mostly the idea of you
know when when
so distinguishing for example the way
that christ when he talks about
uh you are in god and god is in you and
so saint maximus will distinguish those
two
um
as being different
right and so and he will he'll
distinguish them in a way that is top
down and bottom up so something like
christ in you or god in you
is that
christ becomes your head becomes the the
heart becomes the head becomes the
source becomes the the thing towards
which all things culminate so that's the
matter in which christ is in you
he's in your heart of hearts of hearts
right or he's the head of the body
there are differences between those two
but they could sometimes they can play a
similar role and you are in god
in the sense that through a communion of
love
right
you become the manner in which god
appears in the world so you become the
body of christ so we are in christ in
the sense that we are his body and he in
christ is in us in the sense that he is
our heart of hearts or our head so you
can see it's so powerful like you can
see how it's just these two things
moving up you know uh
this up this top down and bottom up uh
ontology is just great and say maximus
all right so arthur holmes brown last
question guys
so
hi jonathan when a person pursues a
profession
trade or business there's an aspect of
personal drive self-made man go-getter
etcetera but there's also an aspect of
the
economic climate
can the economic environment be thought
of as the feminine preparation of the
space while the action of knocking on
doors and pressing through until you get
the job or make the sale be thought of
as masculine
further could extreme free market
capitalism be the masculine extreme
while the extreme socialism is feminine
extreme
um
[Music]
yeah not sure about this last part but
the first part for sure is is is exactly
right that is that you could understand
it and you could understand it really
like uh
you could understand it almost like use
breeding as a or like an actual as a
sexual encounter as an image of this
which is that the
the salesman has to if the salesman
wants to be successful in making sales
because let's say
he's encountering indefinite amount of
people like he's encountering all these
people so he has to be quickly be able
to recognize
the right proport the right potential
for the thing that he's selling
because
he's gonna waste his time he's gonna
he's gonna waste his seed
if he doesn't
if he wastes his energy if he doesn't
find the right potential
so that what he's
selling
or saying will connect with someone who
needs that
you know or can be convinced of that
right um and so you could see it also
you could see it the other way around as
well
which is that let's say you're
um
let's say you're you're the client now
right and you're looking
for
your needs to be
to find a service
or find something which will
which will uh
fill your need right
and so you also have to be attentive and
you have to be able to discern the right
seed
you have to be able to discern the right
company those that are honest those that
are that will deliver what they say
they'll deliver you have to be able to
identify
those that have the proper product
because there's a there there can be a
miss
like the heaven and earth can miss right
you
like
something as simple as right you you
know you you need a cable for your
computer or whatever and so you're not
careful
and then you
someone convinces you to get this cable
or you buy the wrong cable then there's
the mismatch heaven and earth don't fit
they don't they don't fit together and
so and so yeah there's definitely a
masking feminine relationship between
uh let's say um a client and uh
and provider let's say
market you know and and uh companies
all of that
is related to each other
but um
i'm not sure about the second part
though so all right
so yeah
we went over a little bit
10 30. i like to i don't like it when it
lasts too long
so um
so i hope things weren't too crazy in
this chat i see some deleted messages
but uh thanks brad and thanks lisa for
your help at i don't know if there's if
there are other moderators there but
thank you for your help in moderating
this and um and so yeah so month of
december we still got god's dog going
for another month
so it's still time to back it still time
to get other people to back it we're
trying to participate in a change we're
trying to participate in a in a cultural
shift with everything um we're doing and
so thanks for your support all of you
they're supporting me on patreon you
know
like you're really part of the reason
why i can do this because you know
because i know that i've got this this
base then i'm also able to
to to to draw my attention to things
that i think are worth pursuing uh
hopefully to to grow
to grow this kind of symbolic
understanding and the transformation we
hope to see does he happen in the world
and so everybody thanks for your
attention thanks for your time
and um we'll see you very soon so
bye-bye